now ukraine is marking its independence
day today 31 years since it broke away
from the former soviet union but it's
also marking a more depressing date it's
six months to the day since russia
invaded and war began we're joined now
by the mayor of kiev vitale klitschko mr
klitschko good morning to you thank you
so much for talking to us
what are your reflections six months
since russia invaded your country
good morning is exactly exactly six
months ago
february 24 the russia is starting the
war against ukraine
and
right now six months is
a lot of happens this is six months but
today it's independence day and exactly
right now we understand what is mean and
dependency for our country what is mean
territorial integrity for ukraine and
we're fighting for that and
we pay for that the huge price uh lives
of our heroes of our patriots
at a huge price
and i can hear um sirens going off
behind you
is that the reason you stopped all
public um
commemorations of independence day today
because of the threat
it's actually independence day is big
celebration it's always parade
it's uh the people enjoy the days august
it's always sunny day
uh but today is cancelled all activities
uh we listen right now the and the
records
attack can be in any minutes
we
listen to syrian and uh
from from this reason the risk is huge
and that's why the safety is a priority
for us safety of our citizens and that's
why we cancelled all celebration in
in our independence day
do you take any comfort from the fact
that when the war started there was a
concern
and possibly an expectation on vladimir
putin's side that they would come into
your country take your capital within
days and then break up the remainder of
the country from there and yet here you
are six months on standing in the
sunshine as you say in kiev
it's actually it's everyone have to
understand the sense of this senseless
war uh
sense
we ukrainian want to be the part of
european family
we ukrainian want to build european
country with the democratic values with
human rights with pressure freedom this
that is not accepted from russian
federation they they put in told that uh
totally open for whole world
his task
main priority for moscow the rebuilt
soviet empire and ukraine is very
important puzzle in his plans and in his
plans to rebuild the soviet empire and
that's why right now we fighting for our
independency we're fighting also for you
for every one of you because we're
fighting for our wallets for democratic
wallets for democratic future and uh i'm
more than sure the russians go so far as
far we allowed them the
to go uh
the with their in moscow we listen uh
the voices the baltic countries the
poland uh we have uh not forget the part
of germany also just couple of years ago
was the part of uh russian empire that's
why it's very important to understand uh
for what we're fighting and uh we
actually defend right now the same
waters would have european cities
european countries and
we actually fighting for every one of
you and everyone have to understand that
do you think they do
at the moment we're looking at uh
wonderlion we've got footage playing i
don't know if you can see you probably
can't but she's dressed in the ukrainian
blue and yellow and she's going to
unfurl your country's flag she's in
brussels um
but how do you feel as
the mayor of the capital a country
that's
lost in six months nearly 8 000 soldiers
6 000 civilians nearly 6 000 civilians
the international community yes they
give you money yes they give you weapons
now but is it enough do you think it is
enough if you feel that you are
defending our democratic right across
the world
do you think
what the west is giving to you is enough
first of all let's uh every whole world
actually realized what is mean
to solve the to to to show the real face
of this uh
senseless war in butcher paying
customers satellite city around keith
saints international journalists
it's a lot of international press in our
hometown they immediately to uh bring
the whole world the real face real
pictures of this senseless war and after
that uh after these speakers we can tell
it's not the war it's genocide of
ukrainian population the russians or
putin need ukraine
without ukrainians
and uh that's why that's why it's very
important uh
the that was very important unity around
ukraine it's very important
to support ukraine
it's very important to stay together
with ukraine the key for peace and
freedom
in ukraine and
it's
enough or not i'm uh
a lot of questions uh received that uh
it's not enough enough we can say i mean
weapons and support enough enough will
be in one day when we stop this war that
finish this war and ukraine will be
independent and uh also very important
uh never lose our territorial integrity
it's uh our priority and after that we
can thank rematch it was enough but
right now we need support and i want to
say thank you very much uh i want to say
thank you very much for everyone for
british government for united states
government for everyone who
supports ukraine who give the
humanitarian help who
give
the chance to temporary refugees
to be new country and also it's very
important
modern weapons
uh defensive weapons because we defend
our uh homeland it's uh it's very
important for us thank you very much for
your support but right now it's not
enough we need more
um what about the money paid to russia
every day
for oil and gas
basically isn't the west fueling the
world
stop
stop trade relationship with russia if
you send the money to the russia the
russian federation done using the money
for economy don't invest this money for
population they
support his money uh
russians army and
uh it's
if you send the money to russian i tell
that for the business it's bloody money
and blood of this money is ukrainian
blood
please stop trade relationship with
russia
sanction it's very important
it's
have
very effective leverage to stop russian
aggression